[Música]
hace un año el salvador se convirtió en
el primer país del mundo en incorporar
el bitcoin como moneda legal en curso
una medida impulsada por el gobierno de
najib bukele en teoría de esta manera de
las cripto monedas se podrían usar de la
misma manera que se usa el dólar la otra
moneda legal del país pero la práctica
las encuestas iniciales mostraron que la
mayoría de los salvadoreños desconfiaba
de la aplicación móvil que promotor que
promovió el ejecutivo pues temían que su
dinero desapareciera además bukele en
otras son ninguna política pública para
regular cómo sería la inversión en
cripto monedas sin embargo el presidente
afirmaba que el bitcoin sería el centro
de la revolución financiera que ha
pasado entonces un año después para
analizarlo y responder a esta pregunta
nos acompaña en nuestro estudio en
bogotá ana ojeda ella es abogada
especialista en block change y cripto
activos
además de ligar brooks layers bienvenida
a los estudios de france 24 es un placer
estar con usted para mí es un placer
estar con ustedes nuevamente esta vez en
los estudios y sobre todo para hablar
bueno de lo que ha pasado con el
salvador y lo que pasaba con bitcoin y
cómo estamos a nivel del panorama en
latinoamérica con el uso de crédito
activos y también tenemos en nuestro
estudio a nuestra periodista
especializada en economía daniela
blandón daniela vía mérida y es un gusto
para mí que compartamos esta
conversación con ahora muchas gracias
maría clara un tema bastante importante
que nos ha tocado en los últimos años y
que mucha gente menciona bastantes dudas
que esperamos solucionar en este espacio
y sobre todo para nosotros que también
tenemos dudas al respecto ahora
empecemos entonces como lo decíamos
bukele ha defendido esto diciendo que
era para lograr la revolución financiera
y para ello se necesitaban lograr dos
puntos uno atraer inversores en cripto
divisas y dos llevar las finanzas a los
más pobres pero se logró esto logró el
gobierno de buques atraerlos pero yo
quiero hablar yo creo que pudiéramos
comenzar hablando sobre la apuesta de
buque heleno para algunos es un
experimento yo creo que es la apuesta
por romper el status quo financiero más
allá de poner bitcoin como moneda de
curso legal yo creo que lo que el
gobierno el salvador ha querido hacer
para algunos con éxito para otros con
fracasos es romper esa dependencia de
organismos intergubernamentales como el
fondo monetario internacional el banco
internacional de pagos como el word
economic forum y muchos otros que han
dicho que lo que está haciendo el
salvador y lo que está haciendo que le
es arriesgado y que no debe hacerse de
hecho un punto en particular y que
tenemos que comentar es el hecho de que
el fondo monetario internacional está
negando un crédito a nadie bukele como
una forma coercitiva de hacerlo de que
se extraiga no de esta medida en
relación al uso del beat con
específicamente sobre tus preguntas
sobre si hubo éxito o no si se pudo
acercar a la población a este
instrumento yo creo que tenemos que
decir primero que el salvador es un país
que su economía depende por lo menos un
20 por ciento de las remesas por lo que
la apuesta a google en ese sentido es
bastante positiva porque para nadie es
un secreto que digamos que empresas de
remesas como por ejemplo money gram y
western y unión se quedan con un
porcentaje importante de la comisión de
lo que los salvadoreños envían o reciben
así que por esa parte yo creo que la
apuesta ha sido bastante positiva ahora
bien el punto medular el cual
seguramente ustedes les interesa como
periodistas y el cual muchas personas se
discuten es entender si la apuesta a
nivel económico para el salvador está
representando ganancias o no y eso es un
tema que pudiéramos conversar un poco
más adelante porque para mí en lo
personal están y siguiendo acerca el
tema yo creo que él no está pensando a
corto plazo en ganancia en cartón en
corto plazo sino realmente en des
intermediar su gobierno de organismos
como el fondo monetario internacional yo
creo que allí hay un caso de éxito a
nada pero como explicarle también a las
personas que su economía puede estar
basada ahora en bitcoins cuando hace un
año costaba casi un 60 por ciento menos
de lo que cuesta hoy esa alta
volatilidad del bitcoin como explicarle
un tendero oa un conductor de taxi que
su economía va a estar o puede estar
guiada por una
cripto divisa que está fluctuando tanto
ok ahí hay dos puntos interesantes
daniela el primero es entender que el
salvador vive un entorno multimonedas
donde está en la moneda del colon el
dólar y el pico el ministro haciendo y
financia el salvador ha dicho que
solamente el 0.50 por ciento de las
reservas del salvador se pudieran haber
visto afectadas por la volatilidad el
bitcoin tal como tú lo has mencionado
para nada es un secreto que el bit con
es un activo absolutamente volátil que
responde a distintos impulsos del
mercado entonces en relación a las
comerciantes a las personas que lo
utilizan yo creo que ha faltado un poco
más de educación y hay alguna romper es
el que tú acabas de mencionar es uno
entender que la economía el salvador no
está absolutamente expuesta al bitcoin
porque absolutamente
el salvador en el caso de vu que él es
solamente hay 2.300 un bitcoin quien no
representa realmente el patrimonio
completo del país ahora bien si han
habido muchas protestas en el país sobre
todo en gremios como en los empresarios
los comerciantes porque dicen bueno como
yo voy a aceptar pagos en una moneda que
de pronto hoy representa 100 dólares
pero mañana puede caer abruptamente a 50
quien me responde a mí y por esa pérdida
y allí el gobierno buque le ha intentado
después de la promulgación de la
división decir bueno no es obligatorio
que acepten bitcoin pueden aceptar
bitcoin y luego convertirlo
inmediatamente a dólares para no perder
por la volatilidad de la moneda pero
además de la volatilidad hay otro
problema por el que han criticado estas
cripto monedas y es las políticas de la
privacidad de la aplicación móvil que se
llama chivo wallet que es la que
funciona como la billetera móvil y
además de eso según un estudio de
national bureau of economic research
muestran que el 80% de las personas que
descargaron inicialmente la aplicación
no la volvieron a usar en gran parte
porque el gobierno daba un incentivo de
30 dólares a quienes la descargaba
entonces qué se puede decir sobre el uso
de esta aplicación que tanto ha servido
y por qué las críticas de las políticas
de privacidad que además la aplicación
la maneja una empresa privada si yo creo
que las críticas tal como tú lo
menciones han venido por fallos en la
seguridad fallos en la privacidad han
habido reportes de clics masivos de
datos personales de billeteras en este
caso de las iguales que estaba haciendo
un sur para personas su identidad
personas que no pudieron acceder a sus
fondos porque otras personas se
registraban haciéndose pasar por estos
primeros y bueno entrenaban los fondos
yo creo que en el caso particular del
archivo wallet han habido problemas de
seguridad en habilidad para habido
problemas de privacidad pero también
tenemos que entender que los
salvadoreños pudiesen utilizar otras
billeteras para acceder al bitcoin
específicamente sobre los problemas en
este punto yo te diría que la falta de
educación la falta de educación es un
elemento primordial para entender tal
vez porque muchos salvadoreños tomaron
el bono de los 30 dólares y después se
olvidaron de la billetera porque tal vez
no estaban interesados en entender esta
tecnología y en lo importante que puede
ser para su país
también quisiera como que explicará a la
gente cuáles son esos o cómo mitigar
esos riesgos existen con las cripto
monedas porque de todas maneras son un
activo que no está vigilado por las
autoridades en el resto del mundo pues
por las autoridades sobre la que también
se han lanzado advertencias en españa
hubo un evento en el que el banco
central de una vez salió a decir que
tuvieran cuidado con la script o manera
con las que toman edad cómo mitigar esa
ese riesgo de que la persona pueda tener
que tomó nada si al día siguiente no
tiene nada si yo creo que lo primero que
debemos decir y hay que ser bastante
sincero escrito monedas son activos
volátiles siempre lo decimos y quienes
sígueme contenido saben que somos muy
responsables al respecto yo creo que es
lo primero que una persona que quiere
invertir en cristo' monedas debe tener o
debe saber es que debe educarse debe
entender la volatilidad de estos activos
debe entender que muchos de estos
activos no están regulados lo que quiere
decir de que por ejemplo si eres
estafado o si inviertes en un activo que
después sencillamente el desarrollador
el programador desapareció no tienes una
autoridad ante la cual puedas acudir y
lamentablemente vas a perder dinero eso
como un primer punto medular lo segundo
y tengo que hacer el inciso porque bueno
trabajo con él regulatorios y danny es
que hay muchos países que actualmente
están regulando o tienen intenciones de
regular la industria de la escrito
monedas colombia venezuela chile por por
nombrar algunos de los que estamos
viendo en latinoamerica argentina méxico
y en el mundo hay grandes proyectos para
regular esta industria precisamente
porque los estados han entendido dos
cosas primero que son activos que
posiblemente pudieran generar riesgos
para la población pero yo voy a hacer un
poco más emotiva los estados están
entendiendo como están perdiendo el
control sobre la ciudadanía gracias a
activos como bitcoin y yo en lo personal
creo que es la principal causa por la
cuales muchos organismos como el fondo
monetario internacional como el
departamento del tesoro de eeuu están
entendiendo que están perdiendo poder
sobre la población e inclusive sobre
otros gobiernos bueno bastantes
lecciones nos deja este tema y
lastimosamente se nos acaba el tiempo
quisiéramos seguir conversando con
ustedes pero llegamos hasta aquí anna
gracias por acompañarnos y daniela
gracias por sus preguntas no gracias a
ustedes por la invitación y bueno
esperemos que siga creciendo los
descriptos monedas en la región y sobre
todo que nos sigamos educando para
entender que estos activos son volátiles
pero que pueden ser muy beneficiosos
para continentes como el latinoamericano
que pues años hemos sufrido de flagelo
la inflación en nuestras economías